are you spiritual like do you believe in
God are you I'm not a Christian uh I
don't belong to any of the mainstream
religions I don't and I haven't for for
a very long time but I think that uh I
think that life is a is an enormous
mystery uh and that fundamentally for
one of a better word it is a spiritual
mystery we're on a spiritual journey
here I think that the mainstream
religions have narrowed that Journey
Down uh into into in in into dogma and
into Creeds where where in most of the
mainstream religions most of the time
whether we're talking about Christianity
Judaism or Islam the abrahamic faiths
the the monotheistic religions uh people
there are exceptions but but a lot of
people are not having any direct contact
with Spirit they're being taught what to
think they're being told what to think
by basically a bureaucrat uh who happens
to be a priest or a rabbi or a Muller
who's who's saying these are the
teachings you must adhere to these
teachings and actually if you don't
adhere to them we're going to censor you
and censor you in some in some way
another to me that's no more spiritual
than doing business out on the on the
stock exchange you know it's just it
it's a it's an expert telling me what to
think whereas whereas a spiritual
experience is direct contact with the
quote unquote Divine which is not
necessarily
some old bad tempered guy sitting up on
a cloud far from it as a matter of fact
that that is not in my view that is a a
misrepresentation of what of what
spirituality is we could get into all
kinds of controversial areas here I
don't know have you been in direct
contact with a higher power through your
experiences
um yes on psychedelics I've I've
particularly on Ayahuasca I have felt
the presence of the entity that I call
Mother Ayahuasca uh and about the mother
I felt the mother and I felt her and I
felt her teachings and I felt grateful
um because I like
in the most compelling case she took the
form of an enormous serpent who wrapped
herself around my body serpents are
always coming back they're always coming
back and and mother Ayahuasca often
takes the form of a serpent sometimes
takes the form of a Jaguar uh sometimes
takes not the motor car uh the Puma and
sometimes takes the form of um a human
being but but uh is there any fear the
message was no I didn't feel fear I
thought I thought the enormous was
wrapping around I felt enormously
comforted and again I got a message that
I've had many times is that you that you
won't be good at giving love to others
if you don't love yourself if you're
constantly hating yourself and I I've
gone through long pairs of myself my
life where I have felt very negative
about myself so so that you know that
was that was a positive experience for
me I would say every experience I've had
with Ayahuasca has been positive even
the most challenging ones the toughest
um the toughest experience I I
hesitate to share this in in ayahuasca
group when you're drinking with say a
dozen other people
there becomes an element of telepathy or
communication that can take place and it
happened that I was in that I was in one
group where it turned out later we'd we
got the facts later that was one
individual who shouldn't have been there
in
Ayahuasca there's a tendency for you to
lower your barriers your heart opens
your your very vulnerable to other
people and unfortunately and this is a
phenomenon that I would warn anybody of
who's drinking Ayahuasca in the west
today
um or anywhere as a matter of fact uh is
that that there are people who are using
that vulnerability to gain psychic
advantage over you and it was the
feeling first of all it happened to my
wife Santa who was beside me and then it
happened to me of an individual trying
to enter our heads and and and and take
take control of us uh and and we learned
more about him the following day and it
turned out he'd been there the year
before uh and and done exactly the same
thing we didn't know that at the time he
seemed to have developed some sort of
psychic power and when we questioned him
about it he said I'm this basement
Shaman I go around
Ayahuasca groups because I benefit from
them and what he meant by benefiting
from them was basic I'm a psychic
vampire I I draw people's energy I take
it away from them so these dangers can
occur and that's why a good Shaman will
stop that happening
in this case he did not do anything it
was mostly the most unhelpful um but I
think he's learned greatly from that
experience but how does the Iowa
squirrel know that that is happening
well that's that that's something where
you have to tell them and in this case
in this case my wife's Santa did tell
the ayahuascus I was carer but he did
not he said this person is trying to
enter my mind they're trying to take
from me yeah yeah and and there's a
natural tendency to assume you're making
that up as well and you're Lucid in that
moment you're Lucid enough to describe
what's happening yes yes you can often
be Lucid during an Ayahuasca Journey
you're speaking English to that person
there's a yeah it can be you can be and
the person who is entering the mind is
he's sitting in another area is he
hovering he was on a he was on a a bet
not a bad uh a mat on the floor just to
two or three people from us
um and we were not the only people who
he affected he affected other people in
that room and there was there was a
there was a gentleman in that room yeah
literally fell down the stairs from the
ceremonial spaced upstairs trying to get
away from him uh it it really got very
very very dark
um did everyone confront him that they
described it in a lengthy article on my
website uh yes two days later he was
asked to leave
um because because he kind of said I
yeah I do this
um he he I I
benefit from the energy of others and
then what exactly what type of energy is
he getting like how is he benefiting
yeah
um in the case I can tell you
particularly in the case of my wife my
wife Santa and I are both the same age
she's 73 next birthday as well but Santa
looks a lot younger I I I look my age
Santa looks a lot younger and he focused
on her he homed in on her when he asked
her her age
and she told him his agency and he said
you're that young and that's when he
focused in on her it was like she would
she had some energy and she does that
was energizing her and that was that was
making her a fantastic grandmother and a
fantastic mother and the most wonderful
wife on the planet Earth but she has
that energy
no he did not he he what he did was at a
certain point when we were gathering to
drink the Brew he put his arms on her
shoulder and blew in her face
like that now
in Amazonian Shamanism the breath can be
used for different purposes and one of
the purposes can be used for attack that
they fire things called verotes psychic
dots at another individual again only
people who've worked with Ayahuasca will
really get this and a lot of your
audience will not will not get this and
they'll think uncle's a lunatic but but
I'm just reporting to you what what what
happened
um and and um not only did she was she
psychically damaged by this attack but
she also became physically ill after the
attack she developed shingles she still
has shingles as a result of that would
crop up again and again uh on on on her
back in exactly the place that one of
his hands touched her wow so it's just
it's just it's just okay this is great
hold on so there's a physical
manifestation of an emotional and
spiritual experience that she had so if
that can happen within your body why can
it not happen within anybody else's body
why can that happen outside of our
bodies
um well I think it depends I think it
depends on on how much you've lowered
your guard God we're all on guard you
know we all defend ourselves psychically
as well as physically
um but that this is the danger of the
Ayahuasca state that your your heart
opens and and so maybe there's an
argument to be made for let's say that
there was this War on Drugs right maybe
they saw it as something that was too
vulnerable to be handed out to the
masses without a way to if we're giving
them the best case scenario sure yeah I
don't think that we want to treat the
vase whether they the people in charges
with best case scenario but this is a
very vulnerable situation you use people
you're seeing a perfect example of
somebody using it for nefarious intent
yeah imagine the average person doing it
on a Friday I spoke to the psychologist
that does uh psychedelic therapy and he
even reported in a clinical trial these
telepathic sort of Revelations that even
in a clinical trial inside like an
actual medical room there was a person
on I think high-dose ketamine or high
dosilocybin I can't remember and the the
clinician that was observing them
basically thought about their dog at
home this is a purely anecdotal example
but thinking about their dog at home
like oh did I go let the dog out and
then the patient that was on high dose
ketamine took the shade off took off the
headphones and said I'm thinking of dogs
or whatever and was sharing effectively
the same vision that they were thinking
yeah even though only one of them was on
high dose psychedelic okay surprisingly
common real real quick right Mark
how do we build the pyramids how you
organize 20 000 people 30 000 people to
be all on the same page and deliver the
blocks in the exact same ways and cut
them in the exact same shapes and well
maybe not the exact same Chase but to
certain specifications and you end up
with this perfect thing that weighs 6
million tons and is almost perfectly
oriented to True North so it's 481 feet
high you know two and a half million
individual blocks of stone and the
slightest tweak or the slightest
miscalculation can turn the entire thing
off and it won't even be able to stand
up in a corkscrew instead of pyramid if
you make the slightest error down at the
down at the base if you could find a way
to I don't want to even say manipulate
but access that sort of telepathic
ability it's just a better communication
tool for a project of this size yeah so
let's not forget that there are other
tele abilities such as telekinesis which
are also sneered at by Western science
because we do everything well
it's not so much a matter of belief we
do everything in our society through
mechanical advantage we used to leverage
we use the machines which do stuff we
look at Cranes for building so and so on
and so forth
um it may be that there are innate human
abilities that we're not uh that that
have actually lapsed in our society but
but that are still there and this is
where
um again to those who sneer at such
ideas I would say take a close look at
the work of Rupert sheldrake
um Rupert sheldrake uh has is a
scientist and he's done a great deal of
work on telepathy
um for example uh this may sound trivial
but dogs who know when their owners are
coming home now he did randomized trials
where the owners would come home at very
different times and other issues like
the scent and so on were excluded yeah
they always knew when their owner was
coming home not always but that's at a
statistically significant level yeah
telephone telepathy we've all had that
experience I suspect where the phone
rings and you actually know who's on on
the other end how often does a woman
make a part of your body rise without
even touching it
interesting interesting
too yeah
yeah my my favorite type of what I would
say what I would say is that I in all my
books in the thousands of pages that
I've written I have probably written no
more than two or three pages on these
extraordinary possibilities and
extraordinary abilities but when
archaeologists attack me if they say
Hancock believes in levitation by the
mind it's a really peculiar situation
because it seems like you're
unbelievably passionate about this
specific you know I guess part of your
life right but
writing about it even speaking on it I
even can tell as we're talking about
right now you're like people are going
to use this to discredit this other
thing that I've dedicated my entire
[__] life to oh man what a tricky
situation it is a tricky but we don't do
it to other people all right like we
don't look at wozni I can be like your
computers aren't good yeah that's right
no
um so you should have just invented
Apple that's because that's because
there's a narrative about the past which
archeology tells and it's supposed to be
a pretty much straight line
evolutionary story you know it's much
easier to digest like that yeah through
early agriculture to Advanced
industrialized societies and and the
notion that there might have been A Lost
Civilization that we might have
forgotten the whole episode from the
human story is very threatening to that
narrative
um and it's and it's particularly
threatening uh when it appears on a
major platform like Netflix yeah I've
always been attached from my work since
I published Fingerprints of the Gods in
1995 but the level of the attacks and
the characters ramped up enormously
since yeah